Hello, good morning.
First thing I feel I ought
to do is apologise for my
incredibly boring shoes.
But, I don't know if you
can all see this
thing on the table.
I'm quite excited to be here
at The Royal Institution.
It's a famous organisation,
and so I thought I'd and
relate what I'm talking about
to the the Institute.
So I've got something you
can all make at home.
What I'm about to show you
excited one of my students so
much, he made one for his
mum for Valentine's Day.
Are you supposed to make
things for your mum for
Valentine's Day?
I don't know, but he did.
Anyway, it's very simple.
You need a battery, some
neodymium magnets, which you
can buy off the internet or
steal from - borrow from -
school, and some copper wire.
And you twist the copper wire
so that a bit of it sits on
top the battery, and the bottom
has to be touching the
magnets, and if you get it just
right, it will do that.
Yeah, come on.
[APPLAUSE]
Alright, so that will carry
on for quite a while.
A student of mine had an idea
that you could put a
photograph of your mum and
it would spin around.
My kids really like their
mums, obviously.
This is a very, very simple
electric motor.
It's the kind of thing that you
have in your hair dryer or
lawn mower or any other thing
that moves due to
electricity, really.
And this phenomenon was
discovered right here by
Michael Faraday, who worked at
the Institute in the 1800s.
And, it's one of the things
he discovered that
transformed the world.
But he also discovered
something else that
transformed the world even more,
if that makes sense.
And, I've built my own version,
because obviously I'm
a sad, lonely man who has
nothing better to do than sit
at home building models of
things Faraday made.
But this is again some
magnets - can you
see that in the back?
There's some neodymium magnets
- again you can tell I like
those - and some copper wire
again, and there's an LED at
the top - it's a light bulb.
And those things are not
connected to each other, so I
don't know if you can
see the whole
right through the magnets.
So the wires are connected
to the light bulb.
There is no power source.
There's no source of
electricity, and yet if I do
that, you can see that the
light bulb lights up.
So, obviously, I'm producing
electricity, because the LEDs
need electricity to work.
And this is, in fact, how all of
the electricity and all of
the power stations in the
world is generated.
You get some magnets, and
you move them round
next to some wires.
And again it was Michael Faraday
who discovered this
phenomenon.
And this has changed
the world.
And it relates to what you
guys are talking about,
because once we learned how to
make electricity like this, we
built giant versions of this,
which we drive by burning
fossil fuels to make steam.
So it's a fantastic invention,
it transformed our world.
It gave us easily accessible
and available electricity.
But, at the same time, it's
probably what led to some of
the issues we've got today.
Now I haven't got lots of facts
and figures for you,
you'll be glad to know.
There's my Twitter handle for
anyone who wants to follow me.
I'm not actually sure it's
appropriate for students to
follow me, so don't follow me.
What I'm going to talk about
today is, should science in
schools be compulsory?
Now Faraday, like me, was
obviously a geek, loved
science, didn't go to school,
taught himself.
So keen to find out about the
natural world, that he taught
himself science.
And, all of you guys would have
to learn science up to
16, it's compulsory, you
didn't have any choice.
And your obviously here because
you've got some
interest in science or because
your teachers made you, I
don't know.
But, they'll be lots of kids in
your school, like lots of
kids that I've encountered, who
don't really want to do
science up to 16.
They're not really interested
in it, no matter how hard
people like me try to get them
interested, they're not.
So is it fair that we force them
to study science up to
the age of 16?
That's something I'd like
you to think about.
And if you conclude that, yes,
we should make all students
study science, then I'd
like you to think
about some other things.
For example, what should we
teach in school science?
Now, I guess what I'm trying to
get at is what's the point
of learning science?
For some of you, and far too
often, I think it is presented
as you have to do it because
the government says so, and
you can get some pieces of
paper, which than let you do A
levels, which get you more
pieces of paper so you can go
to university.
And, I don't know, maybe that's
a good reason for doing
science at school.
One of the things that the
current government and
previous governments have been
thinking about is the point of
science education.
And some people argue that the
point of science education is
to create future scientists.
So, you know, England can
have people doing
science in the future.
Now, I've just read a book
called Geek Nation, and that's
about India.
And there's lots of Indians
doing science.
So, I don't know if we even
need British people doing
science, because the Indians are
doing it pretty well and
the Chinese.
So, should science education
be about creating future
scientists?
Is that what science
education is about?
There is another way
of looking at it.
Perhaps, science education
should be about educating all
citizens, so that they can take
part in the democracy
that we live in.
We live in a very science driven
society, and we need
people to be sufficiently well
informed, so that they can
make decisions that
involve science.
So maybe we should educate
people at school using the
idea of science for scientists,
rather than
science for future scientists.
However, there's another way
of looking at it which a
friend of mine, Alice Bell,
she's on Twitter as well, if
everyone's doing this
Tweeting thing.
She says that we should all do
the same thing at school, that
we should all get to play with
science stuff - learn about
science - and it becomes a
shared cultural experience.
So that when we all grow up, we
can all chat about science.
I personally think that's
an interesting way
of looking at things.
But, the government, in I
believe around 2006, that they
did come up with this idea of
splitting science, so that you
can have science for
future scientists
and science for citizens.
And I don't know about your
schools, but I know that there
are GCSE courses that take
students down either route,
and those are already
available.
Now, you've learned lots of
facts at school like Ohm's
Law, or Hooke's Law, or
osmosis and stuff.
And obviously there's an awful
lot of stuff - facts - in
science that you could
learn at school.
And the question is, which of
those facts should you learn?
Again that's something I want
you to think about.
What is important?
What facts of science
should you learn?
So, for example, should we
concentrate on the big ideas
like evolution, or should we
look at modern science and
things that are more relevant?
I'm always hearing people saying
you should make science
more relevant at school.
You can probably tell from the
way I said that I don't
necessarily agree with that.
But, there might be a strong
argument for it.
You might think, you know, I
don't really need to learn
about electric motors.
Maybe we should be learning a
bit more about global warming,
although I think they do global
warming in Latin nowadays.
So, I'm not sure we need
anymore of it.
I didn't say that, that
probably upsets you.
Or perhaps, perhaps we should
forget the facts, and look at,
instead, the history and the
philosophy of science.
Again, this was a change to
the curriculum that was
brought in around 2006, where
people thought, hold on, maybe
we don't need to just
teach them facts.
We need to teach them something
called, how science works.
OK?
And I can hear muttering in
the audience, so you've
clearly come across the idea.
And you might want to think
about whether we
keep that or we don't.
It's up to you.
Finally, you've all probably
done practical work at school,
I don't know.
Probably Hooke's Law, have
you all done Hooke's Law?
What's the point Hooke's Law?
You get some springs, you hang
some weights off of it.
And it's probably incredibly
boring, right?
And, Hooke already
did it, right?
So, you didn't really find out
anything new, and the school
has to spend loads of money
buying springs every year
because I know you mess them up,
right, and the weights and
the things.
Because I know you borrow
equipment occasionally.
Practical work in schools
is really expensive, OK?
And here's something some of
you won't know, and some of
the adults might not know.
Research, science people have
gone and looked at whether
students learn anything from
practical work, or not.
And the results are
inconclusive.
There's some evidence that
suggests that practical work
might largely be a
waste of time.
Would you include practical
work in your ideal science
curriculum, or should we
scrap it altogether?
Now, the other guys had lots of
fantasy graphs and things,
and I think I've run out
of stuff to talk about.
Look at that.
Sounds like a sound bite, you
want sound bites, don't you?
These are real issues, right?
The Tory government is going
to develop a new national
curriculum.
And the people who have to make
decisions about what's
going to be on that curriculum
are going to be thinking about
these very issues.
And I don't know what answers
they're going to come up with,
but I'm looking forward
to seeing what
you make of it all.
I'm done, I've probably
finished a bit early.
So, thank you.